how to grow as an artist is to is to do
things that you don't know how to do
right today I'm speaking with the very
talented Zoe Lister Jones so hey Mr
Jones everybody
stars and sitcom Life In Pieces Band-Aid
the movie She stars in MMA you're in a
new film called Bo is a fridge is in
theaters Nationwide writer a producer a
director and an actor it's nice to wear
so many different hats you know because
they're all different muscles to flex
today we dive into the creative process
behind Zoe's newest creation slip the
binge-worthy comedy series that involves
parallel realities and Alternate
identities we talk about making deeply
authentic work the responsibility she
shoulders to empower other women in the
Arts it's always a friend she is a star
very much on the rise and an artist in
the absolute truest sense of the word
before we dive in this episode is
brought to you by Roca now I get asked
fairly consistently about the glasses
that you see me wearing on the show well
the answer is Roca these are
specifically the Hamilton frames I love
them all the frames that Roku makes are
high performance super light amazing
Optics they've got tons of great Styles
they never ever slip off my face and
I'll be sharing a bit more about Roka
later but for now enough Let's uh let's
do the thing
well it's so nice to see you for doing
this thanks for having me back I was
telling you before we started that it's
been so cool just to kind of watch your
career Blossom over the years like
you're just like blowing up and you're
in all this cool stuff and it's
just you know it's so fun for me as
somebody who knows you to kind of see
you popping up all over the place so
congratulations on all of that it's cool
yeah yeah it's been it's been a
particularly exciting year
for sure but I feel like this year is
really a Tipping Point for you thanks
there's a lot of
um High Prestige stuff that we're going
to get into that's about uh kind of pop
in a big way I think right I hope so
yeah yeah and it feels like you've done
so many things but every new thing that
you do is kind of a next evolution of
like
stepping into you know you could just be
doing the same thing but every you're
stretching yourself with each thing like
you go from co-writing and co-directing
or starring and then you know writing
something that only you did and then
writing and directing something that
only you did and now we have slip that's
just about to come out that you wrote
directed starred in produced and you're
I don't know like in every frame of this
whole thing right it's wild yeah I mean
you know like you're the same but I I
feel like
I was a very fearful kid growing up in
Brooklyn and strangely I think I pushed
myself towards things that scare me even
though it's like anathema to who I am at
my core I think especially in terms of
the work I do
yeah I I try to
to lean into to the unknown and this is
definitely the biggest foray so far
because I've never worked in I've never
created my own television series so I've
written and directed and starred in
my own films which is like also scary as
hell
um but to do it in this long a format
where I am in in every frame
um was daunting but thrilling did you
write every episode of slip yeah that's
nuts yeah it was not directed every
episode yeah
yeah that's crazy I mean even you know
the most talented showrunners they'll
kick it off and then they'll oversee a
writer's room just for people that are
listening or watching who don't really
kind of understand how it works
um they'll put their imprimiter on a
show by creating the tone and maybe
writing the first couple episodes and
popping in and writing one here or there
but it's very much a collaborative
effort and this feels you know to be
signature in a really unique way and
just the kind of endurance of of of like
having your fingers into every aspect of
it while also Beyond being on camera
like that's a high wire app yeah yeah I
wrote the whole thing the whole season
in quarantine
um and uh it was really a Lifeline but
it is
uh unconventional for one person to
write a whole season of Television also
unconventional for one person to direct
it because generally you have a number
of directors throughout the season but
um
I had come off of making a studio movie
and there were so many cooks in the
kitchen and I think
it was really intentional that I create
something that just felt
holy mine and um
and it's such a personal story
that
um yeah I think my writing all seven was
was a protective measure in some ways so
that I could go out and say this is the
thing and if you like it then let's make
it but I there's not really a ton of
wiggle room in terms of what it is I I
didn't want there to be compromise and
um
an astoundingly Roku I think probably
it's a function of them being a new
streaming service yeah they gave me a
green light to Series without giving me
one script note which is unheard of wow
so they really just allowed for me to
make
exactly the show that I envisioned which
um which was so healing as an artist how
does it work like
usually in the kind of traditional
conventional Hollywood sense when you
want to create a television show you you
kind of create the the book or what is
it called like the the kind of the Bible
the Bible right and you write a pilot
and you go through these various stages
where you have to get green lights along
the way and all these cooks are in the
kitchen approving things giving notes
Etc
um and you're lucky enough to get just a
pilot green lit but that's no guarantee
of anything but now we're in a whole new
world in which these streaming services
are are green lighting entire Series
without that kind of pilot litmus test
to you know kind of validate a project
yeah you know it's an interesting time
like uh
in some ways
I mean television is obviously a very
bold medium it's like really exciting
and and movies are in a much more
tenuous space but
um there's still a lot of fear-based
decision making so the fact that I was
given the amount of trust I was as an
artist felt
pretty singular as an experience it was
sort of a unicorn
and and so
and to me like any fear-based decision
making in a creative Venture is
just death death yeah
um but but when money's on the line and
and that intersection of Art and
commerce is sort of like knocking loudly
at everyone's door
it's challenging
um and it I think
yeah there was something about this
project I was I was able to make it
inexpensively which I think also
afforded me a more creative freedom
Liberation yeah and um
and I suppose because I had
um you know some some films under my
belt that there was some some more trust
that was yeah sure for me but you have a
track record yeah but it's interesting
you know Roca is an interesting kind of
home for this
um
because on the one hand all the
streamers have expanded the aperture of
what's possible and have created kind of
a tapestry for a lot more creativity and
certainly a lot more you know kind of
content but we're also in a bit of a
contraction with this like the the sort
of Halcyon Days of like throwing money
around and leaving creators to do
whatever they want that's sort of played
out totally at the bigger streamers
Netflix you know Etc and they're reeling
everything back and laying people off
but here comes Roku like a little Sprout
you know like I'm like Roku like what is
wrong isn't that like a box that you
have that like I don't even know what
Roku is yeah like wait they're making
shows now like it's confusing from a
consumer point of view like I don't know
like all these new shows come up I can't
even keep track of where they are and
how to find them
um it becomes you know there's there's
sort of a this diaspora of all these
different kind of places to find stuff
but
you know this is like we're in this
nascent stage of of trying to you know
figure out how to create a media
landscape that makes sense like the
early days of AMC when we were all like
what is AMC you know and it was like and
they did Mad Men never breaking bad and
then suddenly like so it's it's exciting
to get in you know early in a in a a
streamer's nascent stage because I think
there is more room to do really bold
filmmaking and this is
surely the boldest thing I've ever made
in his you know really sex forward and
and
unapologetically sort of centered around
female sexual pleasure and so
um yeah I'm like big UPS to Roku for
yeah
it's definitely pushing you know pushing
the envelope and you know and it's it's
it's kind of NSFW in in certain respects
but very bold and honest in that regard
and yet at the same time highly
relatable so maybe explain like you know
before we go any further like let's talk
about what it actually is so I don't
understand what we're talking about sure
slip uh follows a woman named make
Cannon played by Yours Truly uh and she
when we meet her she's
Restless in her marriage and ends up
cheating on her husband one night and
wakes up the next morning
to discover that she's now married to
the dude she cheated on her husband with
and then over the course of the season
learns that through orgasm she's being
transported into a Multiverse and so
each episode
um she's sort of being launched
sexually into all of her parallel lives
and relationships right so it has this
weird kind of everything everywhere all
at once Multiverse aspect of it aspect
to it that that's kind of you know
sci-fi-esque or or you know kind of
fantasy oriented
um
and yet at the same time it feels very
wetted to the work that you've always
been doing all the way back to like
Breaking Upwards and like when was that
like 2008 nine or something like that
like your first movie with Daryl that is
really grappling with
um what it means to be in a relationship
and and find happiness and and freedom
within the construct of of monogamy
um and and you know this being slip
being written like during the pandemic
um where we're all kind of stuck at home
with our partners or whatever and we're
questioning our lives yeah there's
something very Universal that transcends
just you know relationships uh that
speaks to you know this idea of of
questioning our lives and could it be
better in kind of a sliding door sort of
way like well if you know we all have
that experience where we meet somebody
and there's a spark and you know
regardless of your station in life
you're you're immediately like sort of
future tripping and like playing house
in you know in in a kind of fantasy you
know idealized way of what it would be
like if I was with that person and
you're just playing that out all the way
to the end yeah to kind of experience
like oh well if I actually did that what
would that be like
and how does that then make me uh sort
of consider in a revisionist history way
um you know how I've been feeling about
you know my life as it is in reality
yeah yeah I mean I've always been a Avid
future Tripper and
and I think
it was exciting for me to sort of
narrative eyes like
what the what those fantasies would look
like as you said if they were actually
played out because oftentimes the
fantasy will never be right
um you know you quickly find out like
yeah this is nothing like the reality is
it will always disappoint you
um
but I do think like
as universal as those sort of
existential questions are around like
could I be happier you know and what do
I do with that feeling of wanting more
that in the what ifs and and the paths
not chosen all of those questions just
became so loud in quarantine
um as you said like regardless of your
station if you were stuck in a
relationship or if you were feeling so
isolated and Alone
um
and and so I think this really was my
way of
I guess trying to answer those questions
for myself as I was also
um
you know ending a very substantial
relationship in marriage so it was
mirroring some of my my personal life
and I think so much my work as you said
has been
about the the nuances and complexities
of of relationship Dynamics and so this
was also very much about that but I
wanted to do it through a more
Fantastical lens and and give myself an
opportunity and also the audience an
opportunity to to go on a sort of wild
adventure right yeah yeah yeah
relationships through the Matrix yeah
exactly you know and it's really fun but
it's also like yeah it's like you're
there's there's a very kind of strong
female empowerment component of of being
vulnerable but not shying away from uh
really confronting sexuality head-on
like you're not hiding from any of that
like it's front and center throughout
the whole thing which is like a really
bold choice right and to say that like
Roku was like cool go for it like that
speaks to you know some level of like
confidence in you as a as a as a you
know creative Force yeah yeah I'm so
grateful people to have been given that
much room to explore female sexuality I
think
um
you know I was raised by
by an amazing woman our delist or an
artist in her own right
um who who really taught me to look at
media through
um
like a critical lens especially when it
came to the way that women were
represented
um
and so this was an exciting opportunity
for me to sort of subvert the lens that
we have come to just know
um in the way that that so many
I guess
um yeah that female sexuality in
particular has been portrayed in media
which is oftentimes
voyeuristic
um in nature even though we're not even
aware of it but that that sort of male
gaze that yes through a male point of
view yeah and and the objectification of
of those women in those scenes I think
this was such an exciting opportunity
um to make something that was erotic
like I really wanted to make something
that was going to turn people on
um but that was also messy and
Unapologetic and and that created sex
scenes that were the centerpiece of
every episode but that were very much
from a woman's perspective
um
and very much like
yeah I guess pushing the boundaries of
how much sex we are allowed to see it
it's a it's such a such a strange thing
I think especially in media like
the dichotomy between like puritanism
and and salaciousness and we're always
writing that line and I think
um female pleasure has always been sort
of at the Crux of that right because we
don't really want to get into it right
we kind of just want them to be
um
you know objects of of lust and desire
rather than agents of it yeah but the
device that you use which is
simultaneously kind of hilarious and and
provocative is this notion that like
orgasm is this Wormhole through which
you travel through time and enter into
parallel universes where you have sex
with somebody and then suddenly you're
you're this is your life like that has
always been your life with this person
and then you have to live with that and
that makes you kind of reflect on like
is this better like this fantasy that I
had and now I'm in it is this better
than what I had before yeah that like
Grass Is Always Greener Paradigm where
you then get to the other grass and
you're like ah this one sucks too yeah
you know now what
um but like to be fair is it your I
wasn't clear is it your boyfriend or
your husband husband your husband right
like I mean he's dork fell like all the
way right like you're clearly unhappy
with this guy and unsatisfied but
there's something stable about it and
yeah I mean yeah in the show
um
I I yes the the relationship has come to
a standstill for sure I mean there's
only so much you can do in half an hour
so I didn't want it to be so black and
white that uh you know that you're like
get out of there
um because I think there is like this
sort of
Comfort the Creature Comforts of a
long-term relationship or any
relationship really you know
um have a lot of value and that idea of
home is so Central to like finding
stability in one's life and and I think
because my character is comes from
Foster upbringing
home in general is like a pretty tenuous
thing for her and so the over the course
of the season I think she's she's
um
yeah
sort of pondering the decisions she's
made and wondering if she should go back
maybe less about the person that she
left and more about that sense of of
stability in home and and what that
means and how we can find that
internally rather than in other people
but this notion of of of uh you know
always searching for more or trying to
find a way to fill that like hole that
can only be filled through some sort of
spiritual solution that transcends the
material is is played out in many ways
you know throughout the show and I'm
only at the Inception of the show but I
love the fact that like you know she's a
curator at this Museum and there's this
exhibit and it's called The Hungry Ghost
like obviously you know it's very
intentional like you know I've read gab
armate's book you know the the realm of
the hungry ghosts and like that idea of
like we're just you know we're we're
craving in certain ways and we're always
looking for more and we're trying to
like make ourselves feel whole through
what we can grab onto in the material
world and no matter what that thing is
that we grab onto it doesn't quite get
us there and we're diluted into the
sense that like it just it lives just a
little bit outside of ourselves and it's
going to be the next thing and the next
thing and that gets played out through
sexuality in the narrative
um you know of of slip but you know how
does that like like do you come to some
resolution with that and like how is
this playing out you know for yourself
because obviously these are questions
that you're grappling with in your own
in your own life yeah
I think the Hungry Ghost is
a fascinating archetype because
I've never struggled with substance
abuse but I think we all are addicts you
know and like you're saying that there's
always this
um sort of insatiable
quest for something to fill
that restlessness or or
um
you know vacuous place in our souls when
you finally win that Academy Award or
when you get that you know external
validation that you've been working
towards your whole life then you will
feel complete and you will never feel
complete and and I think that's
you know such a it's such a universal
Trope and trait that we're all
constantly facing
um
and so I did kind of want to look at
addiction through that lens
where whether it's love or sex addiction
or something even
sort of more ephemeral than that just
that hunger that lives in all of us and
how we how we each choose to um to try
to satiate it you know however misguided
the attempts are
and
I mean I so admire all of your spiritual
practices I don't have
um
enough of a steady spiritual practice
but I but I was raised in a very
spiritual home and I guess at my core
like it is something that I returned to
um
when I'm really in need but
I totally struggle with it I think
that um
I don't I don't identify as a love
addict but I'm very interested in in
love addiction
um because I think we all are sort of
you know
craving that connection in a way that
will never be
fulfilled you know in in the way that
love has been
um
designed the idea this idea of love Yeah
The Narrative of love has been designed
to totally right deceive us you know and
so I think it's especially not to make
it so gendered but especially I think
for women
um
what we're seeking in in romantic
relationships uh will always be just
slightly Off the Mark
um and I think that has been fed to us
culturally but
um I think this show does really delve
into things that I definitely struggle
with personally around
intimacy and and sex and and
um
and that sort of addiction to wanting
more
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
well let's go back there I mean you
mentioned your mom your mom is a central
figure in your life if you follow Zoe on
Instagram
uh you know the the the affection uh
that you have for your mom is is you
know is is is is really touching you
know she's obviously had like a big
impact on your life your dad was an
artist too you grew up in Brooklyn two
crazy artists yeah we're both kind of
you know your dad was a photographer
like they're in media they're
challenging narratives I'm sure and
you're growing up in an environment
um that is I would I would suppose on
some level slightly if not you know
altogether transgressive yes and you're
you know shaving your head and you know
being like were you a goth kid like
what's going on I shaved my head when I
was 11. I wasn't a gun yeah wow yeah
um
I was really into scar uh
uh who were the bands I loved the
specials the selector Madness
[Music]
um
but yeah I guess
no no no I didn't know West Coast yeah I
didn't get into like West Coast I was
sort of a
um a purist in terms of that British uh
scene but
um
I was definitely raised in a
transgressive household almost so
transgressive that like the only way for
me to Rebel was to be conservative
um yeah my mom took me to to get my head
shaved it wasn't me like that wow
it was my idea but um
but yeah I think I
I think it was at a time for me when I
was getting a lot of
male attention from older men and I
think unconsciously this is only in
retrospect that I that I think I shaved
it in order to
as an attempt at some sort of
invisibility
um it did the opposite uh it got me so
much attention and bullying and you know
I was it was really a tough couple years
when I
um was playing with sort of gender
expression and androgyny in that way
um
and uh
but yeah my parents are both really cool
prolific artists my mom's a video artist
and and they both made very personal
work so I think from a young age I had
these really amazing examples of
um of what it looks like to fuse
those two worlds I don't I really don't
know any other way I've never made
anything that is not pretty deeply
personal yeah
um at its core but uh
but yeah and and they've just been so
supportive of me throughout my my life
and and pushed me to go further and and
they exposed me to so much transgressive
[__] as a young person which you know at
that age you're like ah I don't know if
I'm ready for this but
um but it had such an impact on on me as
an artist so we think of Brooklyn now as
this you know gentrified you know kind
of uh hipster
Village but you know when you were
growing up that predated kind of that
wave right so the experience of being a
kid in Brooklyn and having these artists
as parents yeah there's no way that you
know you don't you don't emerge from
that with a very unique kind of world
view yeah
yeah I mean Brooklyn in the 80s the
neighborhood that that I was raised in
was um it was definitely tough we were
robbed a lot it was like I I think my
nervous system is
um broken
there's no repairing it
um
and and and also you know but then I was
a part of the the sort of New York art
world because of my parents when I was
an only child so I was being dragged to
openings and events and performance art
pieces and so um is this like abandoned
building you know yeah weird you know
like edgy totally yeah
I I remember like um my mom taking me
this was as a maybe like 12 to
this screening of this Japanese cult
film that was like really [__] up
really [__]
[__] and but she's such a culture of
altar you know and she's so curious
um and I was you know she didn't have a
babysitter so so I was exposed yeah to
to just wild [__] that um and her work
too was really wild and transgressive
and and
um
so it's cool to to see yeah the impact
of both my parents work on my own it's
interesting like we're you know as a
parent
um the whole kind of conventional notion
around
protecting your kids from anything you
know that might traumatize them like not
taking them to you know a certain kind
of movie too soon but all the
interesting people that I know that are
doing interesting things in the world
were the people who are going to those
movies way too early you know so I have
a whole different view on that yeah I
think I thought do the right thing in
the theater when it came out I think I
was like you know five or something like
a lot it was a lot
um but but what's wild about you is you
kind of come out of that like
nitty-gritty you know art uh world but
and and you know and you've done a lot
of stuff in that independent DIY context
but you're very much you've segued and
moved into you know this this this sort
of very you know you've you've been
embraced by you know the the traditional
Hollywood system and you've kind of
stepped into being you know a glamorous
example
how many photo shoots a week do you do
it's insane right well right now with
press there's a lot it's like uh yeah my
Instagram is a little bit Inseparable
but um I do love listen yeah I'm I'm a
real but the choice of fashion make as a
creative are are like feel very true to
you know the ethos of of how you were
brought up nonetheless yeah
um
yeah I mean
I I grew up broke my parents were broke
and they could never make a living from
their art and I think I
really like bore witness to the
heartache of that life and it made me
not want to be an artist I was like
pretty adamantly like
a capitalist like like my parents were
both surprising you know like I was like
I remember someone asking me
in uh in high school like what do you
what's like your main like what do you
want from life and I was like money and
they were like you you disgust me
like I was like I want stability like I
don't
the life that life that I saw
because it wasn't just being broke it
was
um
it was feeling unsafe and well that but
also like the emotional component of
seeing two incredible artists
um
sort of have to
abandon those those dreams that's a
really painful thing for a kid to
witness you know really porous and
sensitive kid to witness
um that both of them had to get
my dad had a lot of odd jobs he was
telemarketer he worked at different
magazines he worked at a video game
company just trying to scrape to get by
my mom
um started teaching video art at Rutgers
um and I think
neither of them ever were able to to
really put the focus on their art again
and the um
you know it's that that sort of age-old
question of like
if no one sees your art
what what is that what impact does that
have on you as an artist and both of
them you know my mom is in is in museum
Collections and stuff but could never
make a living and and I think
it's paralyzing and I saw how paralyzing
it was I saw how painful it was
and when I got a scholarship to go to
Tish for acting I was like no
like to put all my eggs in that basket
and my mom was the one to be like
no you should you should go
um and I did had you been acting in high
school building up that like yeah that
even happened to begin with I had acted
in a couple high school productions
um I was really shy but by the end of
like by my senior year I I was acting
more in high school and then I
auditioned and
um and got in and got this
um scholarship and so
I think also because you know there was
a financial component my mom's like
you're going
um
and and so the financial component was
almost equally as important as the idea
of like you know becoming an actress was
secondary yeah
my mom also
saw that I had love for that and didn't
want me at such a young age to be so
cynical you know like I I think and I
really am grateful for her
um because she's a deeply cynical person
but but she was trying to save me from
that
um
and then like miraculously in one of the
tough toughest Industries I was able to
make a living from from my art and so
that's all a long way of saying
I started to work in TV
before TV was cool you know like I was
doing sitcoms
and um and it was not cool it was not
like something that I was necessarily
super proud of in terms of
um you know my street cred but to be
able to make a living like I was just
like this is the coolest thing in the
world like I this is beyond my wildest
dreams and I'm still just so grateful to
have been given those opportunities and
and to be able
to own a home you know like my my
parents never owned a home yeah my dad
still has never owned a home like
um so I think I've always had a really
pragmatic approach to the industry yeah
you seem to kind of move back and forth
between these worlds I mean like we
mentioned you did Breaking Upwards was
that did that go to Sundance I mean that
really put you on the map that was yeah
the first thing that you and Daryl did
together yeah that premiered at South by
Southwest and that was our first we made
my ex-husband and I Daryl made a
it for fifteen thousand dollars so it
was a real labor of love and teensy
weensy and then it opened all these
doors sure for both of us as a team so
we were really then billed as a but not
like a financial windfall yeah no God no
but in terms of that like street cred
right like Indie filmmaker cool
challenging monogamy this is like we're
a current theme through all the stuff
that you do all the way through slip
um but then yeah like doing all this TV
stuff like you've done like it's a rite
of passage for a young New York actor to
do Law and Order but you did like Law
and Order to the 10th degree like you
did every iteration of Law and Order
like I'm obsessed with Law and Order
I've seen like every episode
it's like a narcoleptic for me like I
don't know why but like for some reason
like when I can't sleep like a an
episode of Law and Order yeah it just
like you know it's
despite the fact that it's about crime
and people doing awful things it like
lulls me into some kind of calm I don't
know what that's what that says about me
um so I've seen you in many different
you know versions of lawn like Criminal
Intent the SUV it's like it's always
funny when you go back and you watch the
really old ones because there's so many
amazing actors doing incredible things
that you see in these small parts in Law
and Order this is kind of like a
training ground I don't know if it's
still the case like they've kind of
rebooted it yeah recently
um but I'm always amused when you see an
actor show up in Law and Order and then
like they show up again playing a
totally different character like they
don't care about that no they don't care
yeah I think I did four
in the span of like a year and a half
right two years playing different people
entirely yeah and they just ignore the
fact that you were yeah yeah showed up
last year or somebody else well each one
was a different you know franchise I was
on Mothership SVU criminal 10 and then a
short-lived trial by jury but um
uh yeah no that's a total rite of
passage and that was
uh
it is really like sort of boot camp
because you you do have to
foreign
body these wildly different characters
and I remember auditioning for Law and
Order and in the waiting room there was
like back in the days of VHS but like
there was like a shelf of VHS tapes of
every audition and it was like Brad Pitt
like you know it was everyone it was
everyone like uh and so you were seated
in this waiting room being like yes one
day yeah exactly like you kind of have
to do it if you have to do that New York
right yeah and I was doing a lot of
theater at that time too which was
really fun and and um and also you know
an incredible training ground as an
actor but I think that like indie film
and gorilla filmmaking for me was
it did allow like I I was able to afford
to do those things because I was on
television I think because I was
bridging those two worlds you know that
allowed for some street cred while I was
on network sitcoms and and then also the
sitcoms allowed for me to go
you know make some really tiny things
that that cost nothing and made nothing
right but a lot of people don't do that
I mean you end up in new girl like I was
telling you before the podcast like my
daughter Mathis is obsessed with new
girl like that's all she you know even
you know math is like that's all she
cares about like there's a certain
generation like for you know for whom
like that's the most important thing in
the way that the office like yeah you
know lives in a certain headspace for a
lot of people
um and in that sitcom world like you
could make an incredible living your
pain your bills and you're able to
create that Financial stability that
obviously was important to you but it's
very few people who then kind of Branch
out in the off season or in the you know
kind of the respite in between Seasons
to go do their own thing and
um
you know the fact that like you sort of
have seized those opportunities with
Daryl and now without Daryl to like
really make sure that you're making the
most of that to build your career to me
reads like somebody who's incredibly
ambitious and and uh and and perhaps
like creatively Restless like you do
those shows you get paid really well
it's great
um but are you really igniting your
creative spark unless you're writing
your own stuff and like exploring your
own kind of interior emotional landscape
as an artist in these other new and
unique ways and and trying to you know
kind of
um create a career path through that
over time yeah
you people get so easily pigeonholed
um in in my industry and and
put into boxes and so I think there was
a
a ferocity to me trying to not be able
to be put into one category too but
yeah I think
I don't know any other way to live like
I
I don't know what to do with it's not
just a restlessness of spirit but it's
like um
a hunger to answer
questions for myself that are um sort of
at the core of you know the human
Journey for me like anything that's
coming up I'm a deeply sensitive and
feeling person so I'm always wrestling
with with you know
sort of deep and existential queries
that I I kind of only know how to answer
through my my writing
yeah you made this independent movie
consumed about GMOs and farming and soil
and that's around the time that we met
for the first time but then during the
pandemic you make
um this How It Ends movie you know like
like what can we do when we're all
locked down right and then you right
slip during the pandemic as well like
using the confusion and the isolation
and you know kind of all the weird
emotions that we were all having and
channeling That Into You know something
that you could express
yeah yeah
How It Ends was
also
both Daryl and I trying to figure out
how to
face like God something unprecedented
that we were all we were all just you
know sitting around having to face
ourselves you know and I guess that's
the most unprecedented part
um
and so that was the story of of
um my character walking across Los
Angeles on the last day on Earth with
her younger self and having a
conversation with hearing herself
because I
was trying to do so much inner child
work at the time and I did not know how
to talk to my younger self I still don't
really know but the movie was me trying
to figure it out um by actually writing
a script between the two of us well what
does that look like like we were joking
again before the podcast I texted uh
Whitney Cummings you were in her you you
were in her show Whitney you know
Whitney you know better than I do but I
was like Whitney Zoe's coming in what
what should we talk about and it's like
all about trauma and her child you know
like she wants to go right to the
psychology of everything
I know
um so that inner child work or even like
kind of uh not just childhood trauma but
like the adult trauma of like
experiencing covid and exploring that
through ART
yeah I mean
we've all got just children wailing
inside of us oh my God and I guess that
you know that I I think those children
are probably in a weird way holding the
reins of our hungry ghosts
um
but I think we all can be sort of
hijacked by very young people and um
and I've
only in the last few years I think
really coveted
sparked a much stronger or acute
interest in
in who that person is and how to talk to
her and how to settle her down
um
and you know I was going through some
major life changes and I still am and
and I think at
at any threshold in a person's life
those voices get all the louder and and
um
and yeah that process of like
re-parenting is is
I still I don't totally understand it
but I'm trying but you're do you like
what is your modality for that do you
have a third I'm in a lot of therapy
yeah I have an individual therapist I'm
also in group therapy which is one of my
favorite new modalities I think it's
really radical
um and cool work
um and in that group are they friends or
strangers no strangers we can't speak
outside of group
um
and uh
it's an amazing exercise in radical
honesty it's basically a place
it's like a safe space
in which
one can say anything
um and say it directly to another person
so it's like in individual therapy which
I also love but it's uh it's a different
Dynamic this is really testing the
bounds of your interpersonal Dynamics as
a mirror to reflect what's happening
outside of group therapy for you
um
and yeah so that's been really
fascinating
um that's a level like in an enhanced
level of trust that you have to muster
um also because with the therapist
they're sort of bound by law but then
you have these other people if they're
strangers you don't even know these
people and you're a public person yeah
yeah that is
that's an interesting element to it
um
that people are pretty cool about but
you know they have access to information
about me that I don't have about them
um but but that really rarely comes up I
mean
I think um
for me like what it's what it's also
meant to do is
um
sort of Replay family Dynamics So within
those family Dynamics like the group
leader is you know the matriarch or
patriarch and and then you've got how
how where you fit in in a given family
and
um
I spent like the the first four sessions
just weeping and I was so confused by it
I called the group therapist after I was
like what is happening but
there's also such um
like a raw Humanity that is experienced
because
no it's not like you're you're taking
turns talking
um you have to find your way in to a
conversation with 11 people so if you
want to like talk about something or
relate to somebody or
say I have something that you know is
really eating away at me and I need your
help like finding just finding your
voice is like such a huge hurdle and for
me as an only child like I've never had
to really do that
um I mean I have to do it in my in my
professional life but
um
yeah so it's been it's just been so
interesting and then people will tell
their stories and
there's so much universality to them
um that yeah so that's been cool
um
and and uh and personal therapy there
was a time when I was in couples therapy
individual therapy and group therapy
every week so like
I was so out of my mind right
um it was helpful but I now I'm only in
two two of the three every week
it's a lot man it's a lot yeah I'm a
firm believer in therapy though yeah but
this question around
monogamy seems to be this thing that has
kind of lived you know in your in your
you know conscious and unconscious mind
for a very long time from the Inception
of your beautiful relationship with
Daryl that like you know went on for a
long time and kind of you know reached
its you know conclusion
um and I love Daryl you know that
um and I know you guys are still close
in all of that but the fact that this
was you know part and parcel of of your
move your first movie that you guys did
together and still gets played out and
slip like what is going on with like how
there's something like very cool about
the the female empowerment piece to that
but I feel like you're still trying to
make sense of of like what that means
and and how you live as a modern woman a
modern empowered woman
um within the the kind of construct of
you know conventional
lifestyle and expectations
yeah I mean
Breaking Upwards as you said was about
non-monogamy it was it was based on a
real open relationship that Daryl and I
were in and and Daryl and I over the
course of our 17-year relationship
um were in and out of of non-monogamy
and I think in some ways slip
was me
trying to contend with with what that
was and what that meant and how to take
it into this new stage in my life like
we became polyamorous in the later stage
of of our relationship and
that you know opens up a whole does that
ever work you know do you know anyone
who's explored that like we have you
know this fantasy that you know we can
live these polyamorous lives but I don't
know anyone who's been able to like do
that and achieve a level of Happiness
beyond what they were experiencing prior
or to do it in any successful way and
I'm friends with Neil Strauss he wrote a
whole book about it called the truth
like you know read that book and you'll
you know you'll get a heavy dose of you
know what the reality of that looks like
yeah I mean
my mom's best friends are polyamorous
um and they have been for decades and
they sort of served as me and Daryl's
mentors they have made it work
um
but
you know like whenever I would go meet
with either one of them to be like oh
what do I do like this is crazy they
would tell me stories that were so
harrowing yeah I mean like the fantasy
of like sexual Liberation you know has
to contend with you know all of our
human Frailty and jealousy and and
pettiness uh you know I I just don't
know that I would I I mean I'm not cut
out for that yeah and there's a level of
at least in my experience you know
because I think it some people do make
it work I definitely think non-monogamy
can work I think that's a very different
thing than polyamory
um and I think in some ways I I question
how much Social conditioning plays into
the difficulties that we assign to
non-monogamy because
monogamy is also really [__] hard
sure you know we just don't see it it
doesn't have the same
um stigma but
it doesn't have the level of complexity
though
it might have a high degree of
difficulty right that's true but you
know it's not the the the difficulty
doesn't live on that exponential scale
of like you know having to manage all
different kinds of people and it just
seems yeah chaotic
it is it was chaotic I guess
like any extreme sport
there's hot really you're chasing the
adrenaline you know
um and then your body's broken and you
have to recover and is the adrenaline
about like like the new because there's
always like the Allure of the new yes
you know that's the unchartered terrain
where the answer lives in this exciting
you know unchartered you know like uh
you know adventure with this new person
and the promise that that holds
I think it's the Allure of the new I
think there is something
uh
exciting and sexy about
the transgressive nature of what you're
doing radical honesty if you can swing
that but I think the complexity really
for me at least a lot I think for a lot
of people it's like
the new is hot and also the illicit is
hot and
the whole point of non-monogamy when
done well is that it is all about
communication and honesty
but you know there's going to be
omissions there's going to you're still
me chasing something illicit on some
level and and and that's I think where
people getting stuck yeah well it's a
very kind of heightened Peak experience
I would imagine yeah and when when it's
when it's like working well it probably
feels like being really high yes but I
would imagine the lows are pretty low
too real low so where do you land on
that now after like we don't have to get
into the details of that Adventure but
as somebody who's explored that like
what is your kind of you know uh
summation
I think that I would not be polyamorous
ever again
um
and I think
I'm still
juries out on non-monogamy I think it's
something that really scares me
um I still am not like
it scares me but I'm always sort of game
do you know what I mean
um like most things in my life that
scare me
um
for me
I think
many people play with don't ask don't
tell in non-monogamous relationships and
that doesn't work for me uh
it's a Telltale situation because I
think yeah
I think just based on on my personal
experience honesty is has to be the
Forefront of any relationship and with
all the therapy that you've done and
that you're doing how do you know like
when you're you know pursuing a
relationship or inexperience
um from
a healthy Place versus acting out on
some
you know uh you know perpetuating you
know some past trauma or acting out for
attention or what have you totally
yeah
I don't know how you know those things I
mean I think I think you know deep down
when you're acting from a
from the Hungry Ghost place you know
like I I will say to my therapist what
is the need that you're trying to yeah
and and I can I can feel I'm like this
feels addicty you know like you can tell
the difference of I think the difference
is really
um
a center of gravity you know when you're
experiencing something from a place of
groundedness versus a place
um
in which you your feet are far off the
ground and from that Hungry Ghost
perspective
can you be okay
just with yourself and not in pursuit of
those experiences with others
and coming out yeah a marriage a long
time relationship and all the Peaks and
valleys you know with Daryl like where
does that land you in terms of how you
feel about yourself and how you engage
with other people in relationship
you know it's interesting coming out of
something
that was really
um
half my life and all of my adult life
it's a difficult thing to distinguish
what you're projecting onto a new
relationship versus what that
relationship is actually bringing to the
table so I guess that's been
um
my biggest question but
um definitely getting you know post post
separation and also post covet you know
which was like wasn't even postcoded but
it was like when the world began to open
up you know everyone regardless of what
they had just come out of was like so
desperate for human connection
um and sexual connection and all of
those things that
um the moment was right you know and I
did have to face a lot of those
questions of what's driving this need
and and is this healthy and
and I think for women especially those
questions are all the more complicated
um sure because I think
you know
historically and societally there's so
much shame around
um around sex and desire
um
and what it looks like to be
unapologetically lustful as a woman
which I think the show really the show
definitely explores that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah well I mean that's
another you know huge theme in in the
work that you do
um and
and kind of
um Carry into how you create your
projects from a professional perspective
I mean in Band-Aid which was really kind
of your coming out party in terms of of
of doing something on your own like
outside of your your creative
collaboration with Daryl to write and
direct your first independent movie and
you got a lot of attention uh for the
fact that you hired an all-female crew
which I don't had anybody ever done that
before at least at that I don't scale so
not at that scale yeah so talk a little
bit about like your decision to do that
the challenges in actually executing on
that and kind of the ripple effect of
having done that
said my mother had had a great influence
on me
um
growing up and um
and really put my attention towards
inequity particularly gender inequity
and particularly in media and so
um I think when I was given the
opportunity to be in charge of my own
hiring practices I wanted to take a
really big swing
and as an actor I had witnessed
I'd witnessed that inequity firsthand I
mean Crews to this day still regardless
of the amount of you know lip service
paid to how much is changing in our
industry they are really white and
really male and um yeah I mean female
directors like I don't think it's
changed that much
yeah like directors I feel like there
there has been a shift and I'm grateful
for it and I think that that goes for
you know
um
for you know the bypoc community too
like there is more of a drive for
um
inclusivity above the line meaning with
directors and screenwriters and whose
stories can be told and that's great but
there's a hundred person team below
those people and it's there that it's
still really homogenized and um
and so I I wanted to
see what I could do to just really like
shake up the system because
I think if you don't draw a hard Line in
the Sand you will just
continue the pattern because it's it's
mostly about
you know
people are very unwilling to take risks
on those with less experience and those
with less experience don't have an
opportunity to get more experience
because no one will take the risk on
them and so it's this yeah you know
there's a lot of money match 22 and
there's a lot of money and the stakes
are high and
um so that experience was
um incredible like truly incredible to
have all women uh surrounding me on that
project especially because it was my
first time directing and I was also
acting and and writing and it was it we
shot Band-Aid in 12 days which was
insane yeah I didn't know it was that
sure we had so little money
and uh and and
and the fear that I found in my
department heads who were also women in
in breaking their own patterns because
they're like I don't know but but my
second is a dude I've worked with for 12
years like you've got to let me work
with him we have a shared language you
know he's gonna and I was just like I'm
so sorry about you you can't and in the
end I think everyone was
um
really grateful that they had been
pushed
beyond their comfort zones
um not and not from a the perspective of
of you know making some sort of
socio-political stance but because of
the process the process was really
revelatory and um
and I remember like
the day after we wrapped my assistant
director went on to a new project and
was the only woman
on the project and
we were sort of living in this Utopia
um and and so I think that the Fall From
Grace was really difficult
um
it's changing incrementally I do think
it's changing incrementally but it it
requires intentionality and um
and a willingness to take risks which I
hate calling them but but it is what
what one would view as a risk in hiring
someone that might have less experience
than um
than their white male counter yeah and
also a risk given that this was really
your first time directing right like
there's a lot on the line for you
career-wise in terms of you know what's
going to happen next yeah so for you to
say it's one thing like oh I've been
doing this for a long time like now I'm
gonna I'm finally gonna do this I have
cred and all of that but like you were
you know just at the beginning of trying
to establish cred in that world and for
you to say no I'm gonna do this it's
pretty bold right and yeah and then to
have your department heads you know have
to do that because then you're in a
conversation around like values versus
like the quality of the film yeah the
quality of the film is going to suffer
because the communication between the
department heads and the people
underneath them isn't going to be
functional that's going to affect you
and it's great that you hired all these
women but if the movie sucks you're not
going to get another chance to do this
right and the whole project you know
kind of collapses on top of itself yeah
and that's what stops progress from
happening you know because I think
that's like any
sort of archaic institution that we're
trying to poke holes in right now is the
idea that but this works but this is
what we know we can't change it because
that everything's going to fall apart
and it's like when you change it
actually the opportunities for greatness
are so much bigger
um and and it was amazing to
um sort of have empirical proof of that
and again like but there is a ballsiness
for you being still a newcomer for sure
to do that as opposed to an established
you know
uh credible director with a track record
of generating box office you know what I
mean like so that's pretty [__] cool
thank you Halsey and courageous
it was cool I mean I again like
you know with slip like there's no
reason anyone should have trusted me to
direct every single episode you know
right like that's a crazy thing for me
to say
I'm gonna do this on my first
series that I've created it's a risk
like I'd never I directed a pilot it
didn't go to series
I had a track record but I do think
you kind of have to
it requires a huge amount of like
humility and confidence where's that
confident where does that confidence
come from is that your mom like yeah
well
yeah my mom made really
bold and and ballsy things in her work
not things
um
but
she was definitely a disrupter
I think she was a disrupter without
I'm sorry Mom a sense of business and so
I think I I saw that as a cautionary
tale and said how can I become a
disrupter and
be a player like
um that is taken seriously in the
industry not very many people can do
that like artists are not supposed to be
business people that's why there's
managers and business managers yeah
there's other people to kind of you know
create guard rails around them to allow
them to create while you know kind of
providing some stability and and
infrastructure
yeah but you have to be like there's no
even as a director like
if you don't make your day you know
however a 12-hour day you're not going
to get hired again generally speaking
and so
you have to and you're also in an
administrative position right you are
the boss of a huge crew of people and so
the idea of like the purity of the of
the artistic experience is kind of
[__] sadly and and if you I think if
you can't toggle those two worlds that's
where you get into trouble and it's what
I witnessed in my upbringing
um and I think uh I've tried my best to
toggle Both Worlds it does require
um it's a world of compromise
right yeah it's like yeah yeah
compromise is so loaded a word because
and that's always the the um
the line you're towing because you have
to be able to play the game but you also
have to be able to trust your gut when
something is
um choose your battles is is a betrayal
of division or your integrity as an
artist and and that's something I think
that is only learned in time yeah what's
the difference between
directing a movie and being a showrunner
on a TV show
um
there's a lot more episodes yeah
there's so much you're kind of like
Manning you know it's sort of to me it
see it feels like maybe the difference
between
I don't know going out on uh an
expedition with you know a smaller group
of people versus like captaining like an
aircraft carrier or something like right
there's a lot of people there's so many
more moving parts
yeah and puzzle is much more complicated
yeah Roku didn't um green light a second
season but they did green light a second
season of scripts uh so
I I wrote the entire first season alone
but the second season I ran my first
writer's room and so that was really the
conventional experience of being a
showrunner
um and that was really thrilling and
cool
um again it is both administrative and
creative and it's not dissimilar to
directing in that there's a singular
Vision that a bunch of other Visions are
there to service and I think your job as
both a showrunner and director is to
create an environment in which
all of those Visions are
in Harmony and conversation and and that
obviously there's going to be a
hierarchy but I think that's like
something that I work really hard at to
create
um
yeah space in which everyone's Artistry
is showcased and that and that that is
deeply felt because I think that's when
people do their best work but it's a
different skill set
the the
challenge of writing and directing your
own independent film feels like a
journey into the soul and it's about
expressing your vision and running a
writer's room is about managing people
and making sure that you're
communicating adequately so that
whatever is in your mind is being
expressed by a collective group of
people right who are sharing you know
that sensibility and are able to
translate that Vision or those ideas
onto paper and onto film and and
maintain like the tone that you've set
right so yeah it's like that's people
skills versus like you know my creative
genius skill yeah but I think the thing
that that
people don't talk about it or maybe they
do but those same skills are very much a
play as a director even on an indie film
because
um
it you know it's like
there are so many personalities and egos
to manage and a lot of the work
is about
creating that
um
sort of like symbiosis that that is a
total wild social experiment that
oftentimes is disastrous like how are we
sharing this Vision together or yeah or
how or how do I communicate my vision so
that everyone is on board to be
servicing it while not feeling hemmed in
or that their vision is not
um
like
of equal Merit do you know what I mean
like it's it's that line because
um
and I think in a writer's room you have
that same thing of when someone you want
to to create an environment in which
every idea comes to the table and is met
with
Intrigue and curiosity and also have the
wherewithal to say and yet that has no
place here and that's really hard
especially for a person who's you know a
people pleaser or codependent in any way
right right right yeah yeah interesting
um
after Band-Aid uh you stepped up and
kind of took a crack at a at a bigger
budget movie with craft right craft
Legacy Legacy yeah yeah yeah yeah like
kind of resurfacing
um this this cult classic yeah
um but that was you know much more of a
studio kind of movie right like
did you go into that thinking well I'm
gonna hire an all all woman crew for
this as well and meet with resistance
with that or you know what was the
process of you know cracking that thing
open
um
well even with that film like
clearly was based on an existing
property stakes were very high because
the fans of that existing property yeah
goth Community yeah it told you to task
yeah and and I was working within the
studio system as an independent
filmmaker
um for the first time Daryl and I had
worked with Fox Searchlight
um together but this was really my first
foray as I had individuated from our
creative partnership so
um
just comes with such a
set a new set of challenges
it still was
the writing process for me I had to go
in and pitch on it I had to pitch to to
Jason Blum at Blum House and to the
exact set at Columbia and Sony and um
my take was still my my way in is always
personal like even with an existing
property so it was really my story of my
my own adolescence and then you know add
a little witchcraft but um
you know of
um
me living with my mom
um just the two of us and and being in
this sort of divinely feminine space and
then her getting a boyfriend and and
forcing me to move in with him and his
three sons which was quite a toxic
masculine space at really such a crucial
juncture in my own
um adolescence and and coming into my
own Womanhood and so
um that was my take and then I you know
added a bunch of bells and whistles to
it and
um
and yeah you know that
process there are so many more Cooks in
the kitchen and there's so much more
compromise and um
and there's yeah even when there's more
money on the line there's still never
enough money you know because
I was making a
big movie that required completely new
tools for me as a filmmaker
um
so
um it was a a very challenging
experience and I think part of me
writing all of
the first season of slip after that
experience was a protective measure yeah
I needed to yeah and I needed to know
that I could
um
and uh
and and yeah then then to see that I was
continuously given that protection by
Roku and and tea time my producers which
is Dakota Johnson's company like
it was really yeah a very nourishing
Counterpoint so how do you know if
you're going to get a second season
depends on we'll find out end of May
yeah so like as of the date of this
recording it hasn't quite it hasn't come
out yet no April 21st
yeah April 21st all seven episodes drop
so uh so hopefully people will binge it
and uh and Roku will so they're all
gonna drop at the same time yeah yeah
yeah I think that's smart yeah I wrote
it to be binged yeah so yeah and there's
there are half hour episodes yeah you
know yeah they're easy
um
yeah I'm really excited it's such a wild
uh experience like sharing something
after it's lived inside you first what
does that feel like
um a bit out of body like very
vulnerable this this is the most exposed
yeah you're very exposed let's just say
you're very exposed
yeah
I'm very exposed and um
so yeah you know
I definitely feel scared and I feel
excited and um
there's so much anticipatory
sort of adrenaline that um
yeah it'll be interesting there's always
a postpartum that happens after it comes
out
um because it is a birth sure and um
and the high of that of of the release
is is so wild
um
and wildly vulnerable and then you sort
of have to figure out what's next yeah
what is the creative process look like
for you you know I've had Stephen
pressfield in here and I've had Robert
McKee and all these people come in and
talk about you know the the kind of art
of creation and the kind of brass tacks
of what it means to sit down and give
birth to an idea so how do you like what
are your daily habits or your practices
around like you know creating these
scripts or turning these ideas that you
have into reality
you know
I don't know where I I have been talking
about it and it's sort of an
embarrassing way to talk about it but I
do it does feel like there's some sort
of cosmic download
like I don't know when I when people ask
me the Inception of these ideas for the
projects that I write I really don't I
don't have an Inception point I don't
have a memory of when it came to be it
generally happens in a sort of liminal
space it's like upon waking or sleeping
or in a shower it's when my mind is
given permission to turn off
I'll get an idea and generally then it
will sit I'll sort of Let It incubate
for
a year or two usually because I'm
working on something else
um but when it persists but when it
persists I know yeah you're like I need
to pay attention to that yeah I've never
been impulsive like I've never gotten an
idea and been like and we're writing I
sort of let it because also as I said
like so many of those ideas are um based
in big questions so I also want to have
some time to figure out what the
question is and what the the facets of
it are that I want to explore but
um I don't have like a daily practice
when I when it's time to write and my
body knows it's time to write it's very
clear to me and then I will write
incessantly for
until I have an entire script
um and I'm a I'm a fast writer but I
won't it'll be all day every day I'm not
an early riser so I'll wake up and and I
will generally just go right to my
computer which isn't the healthiest
thing
um and then I'll just write for
um
you know eight eight hours or something
and then
and I'll keep going until it's done and
then generally when it's done I like
I have to have nothing to do with it for
a week and I'll send it to like a
trusted group of friends
and
it'll usually take them a couple weeks
to read and then in that time once I get
their notes I'll have
at least enough distance to then be able
to revisit it and go oh yeah this needs
to change that needs to change
um
but yeah that's that's generally my my
process for writing and then once
I've got enough notes and feel it's
ready I'll send it to my team and go
like all right let's strategize how do
we get this made which is an impossible
thing to do which is why I've made so
many things independently yeah so a
burst writer but in the interim when
you're kind of collating these thoughts
or there's ruminations around things
that are recurring do you like have a
notebook and take notes do you use like
the notes app on your phone like when
something you're driving and you're in
traffic we live in Los Angeles yeah oh
[__] like well I I need to remember this
like
[Laughter]
so try to talk about it like if I have
an idea I'll try to
because
kind of um
I think it's it's sort of um cements it
in a way if I can say like I had this
idea for something today to a friend or
a partner or my parents
um sounding boards are really helpful
they can stress test it yeah and then
also it's cements it in your awareness
yeah it makes it more real yeah totally
um I have a new movie that has been
percolating for many years and I've been
doing some of that stress testing it
um and just talking it through lately
and
um
yeah I find the creative process so
fascinating that way because it's so
different for every person and how do
you know whether one of these ideas is a
TV show like slip or a movie
is it just how much runway is there to
this story and what's the best medium
because we're in this weird time where
we've blurred the lines I mean what is
television I mean is is television it's
not it's not even really a thing it's
like it's storytelling like what's the
best
you know medium to tell the best version
of this story and then kind of like you
know fitting that uh the right
distribution platform for that
it was designed to be a TV show and I
guess I knew that when but there's an
episodic nature to it yeah yeah and um
I think I also know what medium I'm
looking to work in so I knew that I
wanted to create my own show and I think
then it was like okay what is that show
and what narrative lends itself to
to something episodic
um
and yeah I think next next up is a movie
I also mentioned interested in writing a
book
and that's been something that I've
always wanted to do so yeah like
different different mediums excite me
especially ones that I'm less familiar
with
so is it it's not just the story it's
like okay I've done this but I haven't
done this thing over here yet right yeah
yeah do you have that mm-hmm
I don't know do I have that
I don't know I've been like I've been
doing this thing for a long time you
know what I mean I'm trying to stretch
in a few other areas I'm you know I'm
trying to get another book together yeah
but when you write like is it are you
like okay I want to push myself in this
well certainly yeah I mean you know I
look back on stuff as any creative
person does on things they've done in
the past and you're like really dude you
know so yeah trying to grow yeah and you
know kind of Meet the moment in a new
and and better way for sure right yeah I
think that it's the only way
is to figure out
yeah how to grow as an artist is to is
to do things that you don't know how to
do right and to not be uh so afraid of
the thing that scares you that it
paralyzes you from exploring it
yeah and I think that gets harder with
success
because it's easier to keep doing the
thing like you could just be like you're
crushing as an actor right now you could
just be doing you know like getting cast
and whatever
oh God it's so hard it doesn't look that
way for me it looks like you're getting
cast in there are you showing up in
everything oh thanks right now yeah I
mean it's an it's a nice moment because
I I was able to act in
um brilliant directors films and and
only do that and then create my own
stuff and that's such a nice thing to be
able to do but
but I mean the amount of films I'm not
acting in do you mean versus the ones
that I get it's the ratio is is
impossible and so I it's so nice to to
be able to create my own work
um rather than sit and wait for someone
else to give me the opportunity right
because you can exert some agency right
as opposed to being reactive to whatever
comes to you yeah and to write the roles
I want to play and you know
unfortunately like in this industry
the lists are very small
again the the intersection of Art and
commerce like the lists are very small
of What actors can get something
financed I am not on those lists at
least not yet you know and so like it's
an uphill battle to to get cast
um
especially now that like Instagram
influencers are of value you know like
the the the pool the casting pool is
like even more big and daunting
um so yeah for me to be able to write
the characters that I'm dying to play is
like
a total uh so how does it work like do
you your agent calls you and says so and
so wants to meet with you or will you
audition for this part or or this
director is thinking of you for this or
you know what is the what is that
experience like I'm still auditioning
she says resentfully
um
I do have a a body of work that that
could be called upon if one wanted to
but I am still auditioning
um
so like with Ari Asters movie Bose
afraid that's coming out
um
oh that's out now
I I just auditioned I put myself on tape
um did you so did you go after it no
were you like I want this part or I want
this no my my team like blessed them
brought it to me and was like this
or an ariaster movie and yeah I'm you
know his biggest fan and
um
but I wasn't given the script so I had
to fly completely blind
um and when you see the movie you'll see
it's like a really complicated character
so I had no context uh and I just had to
use my director brain to go like what's
happening so wait you auditioned without
a script yeah how do you even know what
you're doing then you play you play like
uh uh Joaquin Phoenix's the young
joaquin's mother right yeah I play
joaquin's mother so it just came out
like today I think right yeah before I
know talking to you but uh sorry go
ahead no it's it's um
yeah oftentimes that with with like
otters
um
unless you're an offer you're being
given an offer for a role uh they'll be
really secretive around the script
um so I've I've had to do that before
but this one was particularly
challenging as a role and and Ari's
dialogue is so brilliant but it can be
quite obtuse you know so
um
so yeah I put myself on tape and it was
sort of a like whenever I put myself on
tape I'm like you know we'll see
I'm not hopeful
um and then yeah I got the call that Ari
wanted to meet with me and when we met
he he offered me the part I thought we
were meeting you know just as a meeting
but um
that was just the most thrilling thing
in the world and and to get to be in his
orbit and to get to witness his Mastery
of his craft like I shot that before
slip it was really inspiring
um
and uh
yeah but and same with with Zach graft's
movie who I know is on on the Pod right
um I auditioned I put myself on tape and
got the best that's how it happened yeah
yeah yeah you were great thanks I love
that you played you played Florence's
sponsor yeah
and you were like no [__] with her
yeah you know what I mean yeah and I I
told Zach
um
I've seen the movie a couple times now
like he did a really good job of of
being authentic to what that world and
that experience is like for somebody who
isn't part of that world and also
Florence who you know doesn't come from
subculture I mean she's a [__] genius
yeah you know it's she's unbelievable
what she's capable I love like the
pathos that she's able to you know bring
to the screen just with uh her face is
unbelievable yeah it's it's an
unbelievable performance yeah and it's
so beautifully directed and written
um
yeah it was really cool to be a part of
both of those films um
because also you know you create these
little families and now I consider all
those people my friends which is yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that movie is beautiful and you know
this isn't like a film podcast so
there's a lot of people who aren't like
you know
cine East so for those that don't know
like
um you know people listen to Zach but
maybe people don't know who ariaster is
I mean this guy I mean hereditary
midsummar I think mitsamar is just one
of the most brilliant movies I've ever
seen yeah and again Florence Pugh just
like crushing in this movie that is
unlike anything you've ever seen it's
equal parts beautiful and horrifying and
confusing and and I mean just the the
kind of number of conflicting emotions
that you experience watching this movie
so the anticipation of of his newest
movie Beau is Not Afraid is at a peak
right yeah all I've seen is the trailer
um what a gift that you're able to
participate in this movie like I just
can't I can't wait to see it and I
really believe that this guy is like you
know he's among the greats he's only at
the beginning of his career yeah you
know I think he's I think he's one of
the greatest filmmakers of our time and
um
to witness what he's done with this film
is is really incredible it's it's three
hours long I know it's three hours based
on the trailer like it's there's a you
know it's obviously this surrealistic
you know kind of experience of him like
I guess he's trying to go visit his mom
and like there's all kinds of craziness
ensues but just based on that alone it
it feels very Charlie Kaufman kind of
Schenectady New York totally yeah yeah
it's got like a Coen Brothers
kaufmanesque
um Vibe for sure and then
and Ari's
Mastery of
like the visual cinematic language is is
really something to behold like it I I
highly recommend seeing it in a theater
um it is so incredible and joaquin's
performance is incredible I mean the
whole cast is amazing but
um it's yeah it's an epic sort of
demented dark comedy and what is it like
like when all right so ariaster genius
uh like what does that look like on a
day-to-day basis like how what is the
the experience of working with you know
tour who has that level of command and
vision
I mean it is like a master class I I
because I was in front of the camera and
I didn't want to be like annoying and
and like Shadow him when I was right but
you are a director also right I'm sure
you're like paying attention to
everything yeah some level of hyper
vigilance
yeah I mean
what's
I think one of the main things that I
took away from that experience was
the intentionality of
um of his shots like how much he uh fits
into one frame is really like
unbelievable and um and inspiring and
inspired
um
his Mastery of tone
is something that I am also always
trying to navigate
um
and going between comedy and and deeply
felt scenes and horror and it's like an
amazing absurdity absurdity yeah but
something that I really took away from
it was his sense of play and I think
you know
in sort of it's aligned with what we've
been talking about
um with what I set out to create in the
environment on my sets like
Stakes are so high we're doing really
intense scenes he does a lot of takes
but it never feels like punishing or
exacting it feels fun and like
experimental and that there's so much
room because he has a sort of
I mean
he has a complete Command over what he's
doing but there is like a child like
energy that is so
um exciting to be around and and allows
for
I guess just a lot of breathing room in
terms of performance as an actor and and
so that was really inspiring and what is
it like to work with Joaquin you know
there's such a like a such a you know
Mythos that like surrounds that guy you
know I don't I didn't really get to work
with him I only have one tiny scene in
which that we shared but um I found him
to be lovely
um him and Ari had an amazing working
relationship and we just premiered the
film and
yeah he was so sweet and we hadn't
really gotten to know each other came up
to me and talked to me about my
performance yeah yeah it was cool I saw
some photos or videos of the premiere
with you guys yeah yeah I mean that term
and to get that guy in the podcast oh
man he's he's such a brilliant actor
um so yeah just to to share any space
with him on screen is really a dream
come true it's pretty exciting yeah that
movie's gonna come it's gonna make a
make a big splash I think so so right
yeah yeah
um what is it about
a24 like they just seem to be magic like
their fingers on the pulse of
everything's like iced the level of you
know
um
understanding like what's gonna work and
and kind of being at The Cutting Edge of
not just what's cool but what's of the
highest caliber in terms of what's going
to work in the marketplace but also what
is most interesting creatively I think
is almost some kind of magic that
they're doing right now right I know
even with like beef which just came out
which is just like crushing and I guess
they've done some TV in the past but
this is really their entree into
television yeah
you know I guess it is
there
commitment to not being fear driven
right like if you're if you were to
there's a courage to what they're doing
yeah they're trusting filmmakers in the
singularity of their Vision whatever
medium you know and I think that is a
testament to
what creates the best work and what
speaks to people like I think that's
what's so interesting about
when you look at like the studio system
there's such an attention to um
creating something for a mass audience
and I think what's misguided about the
process a lot of the time is that the
ideas that you're supposed to water it
down
and when you see some a company like a24
who instead is sharpening The
Singularity of a vision and that's
what's actually speaking to such Mass
audiences like what a great lesson
I think that's so true yeah that's so
true I think that's a powerful lesson
for anybody who's thinking about
you know birthing something creative
right like the the the the the Resonance
of it is found in the specificity yeah
not in the and the specificity is what
creates the universal connection not the
other way around and by watering it down
and making it
seemingly you know kind of relatable to
everybody you've lost you know it's so
General and and diffuse that it doesn't
connect at all like it's working at Cost
purposes with that goal and it's like
the more specific detailed
um to somebody's you know uh lived
experience or creative expression
um that's what that's what works right
absolutely it seems weird that that
would be radical or kind of like the the
the contrary the hot take I know you
know what I mean but obviously they're
you know they're it's working with them
yeah yeah and
um the proof is really in the pudding I
mean
I also think like
for anyone in any creative Pursuit
making something with an audience in
mind to me is always sort of like the
death now you know like make something
that you want to make like what is the
story you want to tell
and that's what you put out into the
world because when you start to be
I think product oriented over process
oriented
yeah it can get you into some trouble
and yet it is a business and you know
there are people sitting around
conference room tables trying to figure
out if it's going to work in China or
it's going to work in this other place
and those are the things that dictate
budgets
yeah I mean when I say it's like
figure out what story you want to write
if if I was talking to like a filmmaker
I would say figure out what store you
want to write
what sort of you have to write
um and then think about a way to make it
cheaply you know like I'm not taking
business out of the equation because I
think you do have to be pragmatic if you
if you're a first-time filmmaker and you
write some huge epic it's never going to
be sure and that might be the story you
think you need to tell but what's if you
distilled that story down what's the
contained version of it and then go you
know figure out a way to make that
because
uh every single project I've ever made
has had 1 000 no's before there's been
any yes so how do you like weather the
rejection
because you're in a business you're
you've become very successful in this
business but it's a business of like you
said you know mostly knows yeah and
being able to kind of like hold true to
yourself and and what you're doing and
not you know get overly dissuaded by
that
I guess it comes it comes back to
confidence which is hard right like
because nose will
uh diminish your confidence
I've always had something
where I don't believe them it doesn't
mean that I
it doesn't mean that I don't take notes
right like if if someone says no I have
to look at what they're saying no to and
what I can shift
but um
it requires such tenacity to keep going
and that tenacity is ultimately like
an unwavering sense of self or
a sense that
you have something that deserves a voice
um
and I don't know
I don't know how how to cultivate that
necessarily except for to just keep
going I think you just have to keep
going and I think making your own work
is really important like Daryl and I
made work in the face of 1000 no's by
just going and doing it ourselves
and you know that's a real stress test
of the work yeah I feel like
um just in looking at like the projects
that you guys did together you it feels
like you just pulled the [__] out of
your ass like you're like well we're
gonna go make this movie and I'm like
what and then like somehow you're like
out in the street like shooting like you
just you progress as if like even if all
the pieces aren't together like you're
just in motion moving forward and you
know when you create that momentum
somehow everything else you know those
other problems that seem insurmountable
start to get resolved
I mean you know it's like
manifesting I guess one-on-one it is
like
I am doing it you can tell me no and I
can take a note and shift something you
can tell me no and say well we have
something else like it which is what
you're always hearing or you know like
and it's like well but do you and can't
there be many things that are in the
same world but have different voices
behind them and
um
yeah I guess it is about in some ways
pulling it out of your ass what's the
like worst piece of advice that you've
gotten from some kind of like Studio
person or I'm sure you've heard some
bangers yeah
[Laughter]
oh God
we're not naming names I know I'm trying
to think of like like
worst piece of advice
sadly like
it's almost more diminishing than bad
advice it's it's really just ad hominem
yeah I think it was more when I was
young and I've named this name before
and uh I'll name him again but I I went
to David mammoth's acting school and um
and I was 18 and he came
uh and give a guest class and told me
that
um my shelf life was short as an actor
and um
that's probably the worst wow the worst
piece of advice I've ever been given
if you could call it advice
it's like someone just took like a
steaming [__] yeah and like
yeah oh man that could not have been fun
no but you know then later
he he saw a sketch that I had written
and he was notoriously cruel and said
who wrote that I said I did and he said
you should write a feature so
you know interesting you should write
him a letter now
this is my letter to him okay David dear
David Zoe is on the scene
um uh conversely what about like some of
the best advice that you've gotten over
the years
well
I guess the best advice I ever was given
uh was by a producer named Alex Madigan
who took me to coffee and said you
should direct
and I didn't know that and it's like a
wildly simple piece of advice but I
think that it does take
sometimes I think it for many people but
especially for women and especially for
women in film like
this sense of confidence even if you
don't know or if you haven't gone to
film school if you don't have any every
answer you don't know every lens you
know
that someone saw that and said
go do it you got it and that's really
all it took to have that outside
external voice see something in you that
maybe you're not ready to see in
yourself yeah which I think has happened
for me
every time I mean that David Mammoth
story was that for me too I was I was
writing but I wasn't like no I should go
write a feature you know and
um even when I was in high school and I
was acting I I was in the chorus of a
musical I had no confidence as an actor
and some like parent in the PTA was like
you're really good you're the one I'm
watching in the background and
and so I guess
tell people when you think they're
talented because it's really meaningful
and it's a really hard World across all
Industries and those are are really
character building moments in terms of
giving someone
yes a sense of value in in the craft
they might be interested in but too
afraid to pursue yeah
um I like that you know I think that you
don't yeah also you know as somebody
who's older you don't know the impact
that your words have on somebody else
and when I reflect back and I remember
certain things that certain people said
to me I'm sure they have no memory you
know like that nice thing that they said
and those things really can be
meaningful yeah yeah
um
obviously uh
[Music]
um
equity and empowerment are are really
important subjects to you in terms of uh
you know trying to you know build on on
ramps to you know a career in this
business that you're in and kind of
changing the landscape or in the you
know we're in the we're still you know
kind of in the wake of Harvey Weinstein
and you know me too and all that kind of
stuff and you've been you know a really
kind of powerful voice in that
conversation uh what's your sense of of
kind of
changes that have been made changes that
still need to be made like I feel like
the whole kind of streaming situation
everything's sort of up in the air and
it makes it Rife for reinvention and new
models like we just saw what Matt Damon
and Ben Affleck are doing with artist
equity and you know basically they've
created this new production company
where all the crews are participating on
an equity basis in these projects and
that's something that's never been done
before and it's [__] awesome and so I
think there is real opportunity to kind
of rewrite the rules and and you're
somebody who I know thinks a lot about
this and has taken action on this so
like where where's your head at with all
of that right now
um
I guess my head is is like
I feel hopeful I do feel hopeful
I think there are there have been
strides that have been made and I think
there's still a really long way to go
yeah and um
and it requires a huge amount of
intentionality
um
from the people at the top
and uh
and I guess yeah my hope is that
it won't just be for Optics you know
that people see the actual inherent
value in diversifying voices in a room
and um
and and
changing you know changing up who's also
in charge
um but
you know
it's wild I think how far we still do
have to go like I I said I say I say
that I have hope and I do but um
just yesterday I I did an interview with
like an esteemed publication and the
journalist said what's it like to fake
so many orgasms you must have done that
in your real life a bunch too and I
thought God let's get to the real
important stuff so far to go man like
that's yeah top of mind for you to ask
me
um
and and I do think in some ways slip is
going to be an interesting test in terms
of what
you know
the discourse will be around it
yeah and what yeah what the discourse
will be around
my exploration of sexuality and female
pleasure and
um
I hope that it pushes the envelope
um in a good way because I do think that
um
that's a part of it you know like but in
the wake of of me too which you know
we're still in many ways but
um
that
that I think one of the most threatening
things is is women's sexual I mean we
look at it with women's Reproductive
Rights it's like
the fact that Roe v Wade has been
overturned it's
just unbelievable the power
we hold you know and and how threatening
that power is
um
and I hope that uh there's some way to
shift the the perspective
it's the same thing about equity and
inclusivity it's like this idea that if
we change it it's gonna be a mess or the
people who have been in power so long
have to feel a threat rather than a
sense of excitement at
um
not even you know a change a change of
guard but like
what that could open up for the World At
Large and and for the guard themselves
you know or just a paradigm shift in
perspective from perceiving it as a
threat to perceiving it as the greatest
opportunity yeah for growth and you know
kind of nourishment and and economic
viability yeah yeah and
you know you look at trans rights just
being demolished across the country at
the same time as Reproductive Rights and
the same time as racial inequity and
um
in some ways you know the the pushback
has allowed for so many more voices to
come into the fold where
um you know all of these incredible
trans Advocates are are are being you
know are using their platform to say
we're all in this like you know and
parents of trans guys and all of that is
like
I feel inspired amidst the the sort of
Bleak atmosphere that we're in because I
do think we're at we're at a Crossroads
um
it's just going to take some time yeah
yeah I feel like
um
the entrenchment around
Hollywood specifically is
not under threat is the wrong word but
um
is you know being challenged to
uh
you know reimagine itself yeah and I
feel like that's happening in some
respects and on in other ways there's a
holding on to an old way of doing things
which I guess is natural this is the way
it always is with everything yeah but I
feel like those changes are inevitable
so I'm optimistic and I think it's a
really interesting time yeah you know
and for yourself as a as somebody who's
creating in that space in this space
um there's so much more I mean the fact
that you're like making the show with
Roku like there's so many Avenues and
opportunities to do cool things and
they're leaving you alone and you're
going to do all this kind of stuff like
that didn't exist yeah that long ago
um and we're at this point now where
it's like there's so much [__] like I
have to go you know I have to talk to
other people and go online and like what
should I be watching like there's so
many so much great awesome stuff out
there
um whereas it used to just be like we're
just waiting for that one thing for
months you know to like nourish us and
and now we're in this Cornucopia yeah
you know pursue yeah it is an exciting
time and yet the business model of it
has changed right there's no syndication
money you know like all the back end and
all that kind of stuff so so all the
economics of it are being upended and
everyone's trying to figure out like a
new way
yeah and network television is freaking
out as they should be I mean that's
that's [__] some broke ass [__] right
there right it's amazing it's still
holding on in the way that it is like
get over it already you know what I mean
or push yourself to make
you know Bolder choices right right and
you say that as somebody who's done the
sitcom thing yeah like it's wild that so
many people watch that [__] still so
many people I know and it bought me a
house so God bless all those
um all right well the last thing I want
to kind of pursue with you before you
know releasing you to your life is is
just you know in in kind of closing here
I always want to try to leave people
with some inspiration around
engaging or re-engaging with their own
creativity and their own voice in
perhaps a way that people feel like
they don't have permission to like
you're in this world like this is your
job right for but for most people like
they're doing other stuff and I'm of the
firm belief that we're all creative
beings and we all have a voice and we
all have something interesting to say
and there's no one else out there you
know you are your own you know you are a
unique being and I'm always encouraging
people to kind of explore that and find
a way to bring expression
to your unique lived experience so you
know how do you kind of encourage that
in individuals or or think about how you
do that yourself
well I think
an exciting thing about this moment in
the world and while social media is uh
you know a nightmare hellscape it is
also
a way for people to see that
uh there are weirdos like them
everywhere you know I mean I identify as
a weirdo too
when I was growing up I didn't I didn't
know you know necessarily how to find
the weirdos or how to feel less alone
and
what to do with those feelings of
alienation
um
and so
I I hope that people are emboldened to
tell their stories in whatever way they
they want to right like there's so many
modes of self-expression but
I think what I've learned in all of my
therapies
is that um depression is when rage is
turned inwards or when when you know
you're collapsing in on yourself because
you there's not a mode of expression and
so um so I'm a firm believer in figuring
out what that mode of expression is
um because I do think it's it's what
will save your life
yeah I think that's wise you know rather
than pushing it down finding a way to
shine a light on it and expose it in a
way yeah deconstruct it for yourself
and share it in a way that creates a
sense of bond with the other people who
are feeling that way because we all feel
alone in those weird emotions that we
have we all feel alone all the time yeah
and like uh whenever I'm asked what I
want audiences to take away from slip or
anything I make I just say I want them
to feel less alone because it is why I
make things
yeah it's the most powerful
tool you know and the most and and such
a transformative experience as a viewer
for me when I see something and and feel
less alone that's like that's why we
that's why we consume art I mean in slip
there there is this sense that you are
very alone in this relationship you know
you're you're in this you know intimate
relationship but there's a severe lack
of intimacy and you're trying to figure
out like what am I doing here
you go on this adventure
um and whatever ensues ensues but I
think there's something Universal in
that like the idea that we're in our
lives but we're always thinking about
like would our life be better if we were
over here as opposed to here and that's
connective tissue that you know I think
we can all you know relate to deeply
yeah especially
at this moment you know sort of post
pandemic
it
I think a sense of aloneness
is something
deeper than we've ever been willing to
really talk about and um
and I think talking about it is
a great thing I I think it is one of the
most profound
experiences I've had in the aftermath of
of quarantines that when you ask people
how they are now they actually tell you
right yeah that's true right they're
like not great
life's hard
um and that's I think that's important
true
um
oh cool man I think we did it yeah thank
you thank you it's so nice to be back in
this beautiful new space I love you Zoe
I love you too I'm such a fan and uh
like I said at the outset it's been so
fun uh to watch your kind of career take
off in the way that it has it's it's
well deserved and I can't wait to see
what you do next so you've got slip
coming by the time this podcast comes
out it will be out on Roku Beau is Not
Afraid in movie theaters wherever we
live right worldwide yeah I think so um
and then what else do you have anything
else coming out
no we'll just uh if you watch Roku and
watch slip season one then you'll help
me get a season two all right there we
go let's
crowdsource uh season two for Zoe
where's the deal right yeah cool cool
thanks thank you